شكرا لك ايمان ومرحبا بكم مشاهدينا هذه
النافذه للتحليل العسكري لمجريات حرب
اسرائيل على قطاع غزه في هذه النافذه
كالعاده نستضيف المحلل العسكري اللواء
فايز دويري وفي هذه النافذه ايضا نطلع على
اخر التطورات الميدانيه في شرح مفصل لها
عبر الخريطه التفاعليه والزميله سلام خضر
التي ستبدا معنا في هذه الفقره تفضل شكرا
حسن في اليوم 120 للحرب الاسرائيليه على
قطاع غزه ما زال شمال القطاع يفاجئ
بالمعنى العسكري والميداني جميع المتابعين
وايضا قوات الاحتلال من الشمال سنبدا
اليوم حصلت قناه الجزيره على صور حصريه من
منطقه الشمال من منطقه غزه تحديدا مدينه
غزه لا تزال في قلب الاحداث الذي يجري في
غزه وفي جوار مدينه غزه في حي الرمال وما
بينهما هناك اشتباكات وصفت بانها عنيفه
وتظهر الصور التي حصلت عليها الجزيره بان
القتال يدور في المنطقه العل تقريبا
الشماليه الغربيه من مدينه غزه هناك
اشتباكات تخوضها فصائل المقاومه قرب
المنطقه المحيطه بمستشفى الشفاء هذه
الاماكن التي تقع فيها اليوم هذه
الاشتباكات كانت قوات الاحتلال عندما بدات
ما تسميه المناوره البريه او الهجوم البري
قد وصلت الى هذه المنطقه تقريبا في الحادي
عر او في بين الثامن والحادي عر من شهر
اكتو من شهر نوفمبر بمعنى انها دخلت الى
هذه المناطق في الاسابيع الاولى للعمليه
البريه وقبل اسبوعين اعلنت انها انتهت من
العمليات اليوم عدنا لنرى هذه الاشتباكات
والمفاجئ ايضا ليس وقوع اشتباكات فقط ولكن
قالت القوات الاسرائيليه بنفسها انها عثرت
في مخيم الشاطئ تقريبا عند هذه النقطه على
نفق تستخدمه المقاومه وكما يبدو هذا النفق
مجهز بامور لوجستيه متعدده من بينها مصعد
ما قد يشي بان هذا النفق التي اعلنت عنه
قوات الاحتلال قد يكون من الانفاق متعدده
الطوابق هذا النفق اعلن عنه اليوم نحن في
اليوم ال 120 للحرب الاسرائيليه على قطاع
غزه بمعنى انهت قوات الاحتلال اربعه اشهر
من القتال لتعثر اليوم على هذا النفق ولكن
لا تقتصر الامور الميدانيه والتطورات
الميدانيه على ما يجري في المنطقه
الشماليه خانيونس المحافظه وخانيونس
المدينه ما زالت ايضا محور اشتباكات عنيفه
جدا ما جرى اليوم ان مدينه خانيونس التي
تحاول قوات الاحتلال التوغل اعمق بداخل
المدينه شهدت اشتباكات عنيفه واعلنت كتائب
عده من المقاومه من بينها سرايا القدس
انها استهدفت القوات الاسرائيليه واليات
تابعه للقوات الاسرائيليه في منطقه
خانيونس طبعا حسن هذه تحتاج الى قراءه
اعمق والى تحليل ومزيد من التفاصيل بطبيعه
الحال معك واللواء الدويري شكرا لك سلام
مرحبا بك من جديد سيد فايز
الدويري وانا اشاهد الخريطه التي تقدمها
الزميله سلام يعني تبادر الى ذهني سؤال
قوات الاحتلال تتحدث عن سحب لالو ولقوات
وتخفيف قواتها في قطاع غزه الان لم نعد
نسمع عن محاولات تقدم ومحاولات صد لعمل
عمليات التقدم بمعنى اننا لم نعد نفهم ما
الذي يحصل في غزه ا كان شمالا او وسطا او
حتى جنوبا ماذا يفعل تفعل قوات الاحتلال
في الداخل يعني هو من لما اعلن عن دخول
هذه المنطقه بالمرحله الثالثه بدات عمليات
التخفيف ومن ثم
الانسحاب منذ اول امس اعلن منذ صباح اول
امس اعلن ان الوحدات المتواجده في هذه
المنطقه
تم سحبها اي غالبيتها العظمى الى غلاف غزه
امم في عمق خمسه الى 15 م شمال وشرق لكن
طيله الفتره الماضيه كان هناك عمليات دخول
وخروج يعني الان كان هناك عمليه مراقبه
وافراط في استخدام الطائرات المسيره كواد
كابتور وغيرها من الطائرات وبالتالي هذه
كانت تصور على مدار الساعه تقريبا وتنقل
المعلومات
مجرد ان يكون لديهم اشتباه بان هناك
مقاتلين او هناك معلومات عن رهائن او هناك
معلومات عن انفاق تعود هذه القوات الان
الامر المختلف في هذه في هذا اليوم انه
طبيعه القوات التي دخلت ليست من الفرقه
162 انما جاءت من وادي غزه طيب اليوم وكما
نشاهد في هذه الصور هذه من محيط مستشفى
الشفاء في غزه
في هذه الصور الحصريه التي حصلت عليها
الجزيره نسمع اصوات
اشتباكات قوات الاحتلال موجوده في هذه
المنطقه هي
تحاصر مستشفى الشفاء ومن هم بداخله لكن
واثناء اعداد هذا التقرير تسمع اصوات
اشتباكات ما هدف هذه الاشتباكات يعني ماذا
يريد جيش الاحتلال في الداخل دخلت القوات
من وادي غزه لانه كان هناك معطي يات
ميدانيه هذه المعطيات قد يفسرها البعض
بانها بحث عن اهداف وقد تفسر في الجانب
الاخر بانها نوع من الاستدراج يعني هذه
يعني هذه هذه الحركات التي تعملها
المقاومه هي نوع من الاستدراج للقوات
لتدخل لانه ما دامت القوات خارج مدى
الاسلحه الان لا يوجد اي قدره او امكانيه
لدى المقاومه لتتعامل معها اقصى ما يمكن
ان تتعامل معها بقذائف الهاون بينما
المعارك الرابحه بالنسبه للمقاومه هي
معارك مسافه الصفر وبالتالي الان بدات بعض
النشاطات كبعد تحليلي للمقاتلين لانه تم
اعاده تاهيل لواء غزه ولواء الشمال و
ومجموع الكتاب 12 كتيبه حد الادنى اصغر
كتيبه
850 واكبر كتيبه
وبداوا ليس فقط قط الاشراف العسكري لا
محاوله ادامه الحياه المدنيه مما يعني ان
هذا التنظيم قد اعاد بناء قدراته وانه هو
المستقبل هنا دخلت هذه القوات من منطقه
الشيخ عجلين لانه اذا تتبعنا الاحداث كانت
بدايه المعارك في الشيخ عجلين انتقلت الى
الى تل الهواء انتقلت الى
اطراف المشفى والان انتقلت اعمق من ذلك
بحدود واحد ونص
طيب مربع الجامعات وال كل هذا النشاط
العسكري كل هذا النشاط
العسكري يعيد طرح السؤال الاول ما الذي
حقق هذا النشاط العسكري عمليا من اهداف
وما الذي تحققه قوات الاحتلال الان من
تواجدها هذه الصور هي صور لجنود قوات
الاحتلال في منطقه الشاطئ هي تتحدث عن
اكتشاف نفق ونفق بطوابق متعدده فيه مصعد
كما تقول قوات الاحتلال لكن يعني بعد كل
هذه الفتره الطويله نصل الى
اي مستوى اكتشاف هذا الن متى دخلوا المره
الاولى الى الشاطئ دخلوا الى الشاطئ في
الاسابيع الاولى من المعركه البريه من
المرحله الاولى قبل الهدنه يعني الدخول
الى الشاطئ كان قبل الهدنه وبالتالي اي
دخلوا دمروا تقريبا الشاطئ لم يبقى منه
الا بعض الابنيه ورغم ذلك لم يستطيعوا
اكتشاف الان في عمليات الدخول والمراقبه
المستمره في الفتره الاولى كان دور
الطائرات المسيره والطائرات الكواد كابتور
محدود جدا الان بداوا يعتمدوا عليها كثيرا
فبالتالي هي تنقل صور حيه يمكن شاهدوا
حركه خرجت من منطقه معينه الان وصلوا الى
هذا النفق لكن هل يعتبر انجاز انت تتحدث
عن 1300 نفق بعد 120 يوم استطعت ان تصل
الى نفق هذا ما هو الحد الاقصى حسب ويست
بوينت 720 م طول الانفاق وعددها 1300 نفق
طيب رب قائل لك سيدي دويري ان جيش
الاحتلال سيبقى وهو اعلن انه سيبقى في
مدينه غزه وان عمليات او في غزه القطاع
عموما وان عملياته لم تهي بعد وبالتالي
كما اكتشف هذا النفق
ستاتي اوقات ويكتشف انفاقا اخرى وبالتالي
هذهه العمليات
ان كثرت او قلت لكنها مستمره ولوقت طويل
نعم هذا العمليه هذا ما يقوله هل سيستطيع
البقاء والاستمرار هنا السؤال ام الان
بدات المقاومه في الشمال تعيد ترتيب
اوراقها وبالتالي يحتاج الى عمليه موسعه
على غرار العمليه السابقه وهذا ما تحدث به
هاليفي رئيس الاركان قال سنجبر على خو اذا
الان يصبح الدوران في حلقه مفرغه الى
متى الان حتى على مستوى المنطقه العازله
اللي بتحدث عنها وبده ينشئها الم ينشئ
المنطقه العازله مرتين قبل ذلك وبالتالي
اخرج منها هو لم يخرج اخرج منها وفي المره
الاخيره كانت خروجه بسبب مسيرات العوده
بسبب القتال اذا الان هو يقول سيبقى انا
اقول لن يستطيع البقاء لانه فاتوره
التكاليف تبقى في تساعد بالحديث عن فاتوره
التكاليف هنا ربما الاستهدافات التي اي
تنقل مشاهدها المقاومه ا كانان باستهداف
الاليات او قنص الجنود والان هذا ال هذه
الصور لسرايا القدس استهداف لتحشيد قوات
الاحتلال بقذائف الهون ربما هذا يجيم على
بشكل او باخر ان كانت قوات الاحتلال قادره
على البقاء ما دام
هناك استهداف لها ما دامت المقاومه موجوده
ومتماسكه وقادره على اداره المعركه
الدفاعيه ستبقى فاتوره التكاليف باهظه وقد
يتحملها لفتره من الزمن لكن بعد لحظه
معينه لن يستطيع وخاصه الان هناك
التهديدات بالانشقاق
ايزنكوت وغيره من من مجلس الحرب ورغم انه
زعيم المع عرضه عرض نوع من طوق النجاح
لنتنياهو للوصول الى اتفاق ليحل مكانهم في
في حكومه طوارئ ويخرج سموتريش وبن كفير
الان هو يقول ما يشاء لكن الميدان هو صاحب
القول الفصل وبالتالي احن لا ننكر حجم
المعاناه التي تعانيه غزه لم تعانيه اي
منطقه اخرى عبر التاريخ و 2.3 مليون كلهم
في حاله بؤس وفي حاله تعب وارهاق وغير ذلك
لكن الحريه ثمنها باهظ طيب
اي ستبقى معنا طبعا لواء فاز الدويري
وللاشارة نموذجا لما يسمى حرب المدن بعض
اوجه صعوبات القتال في المدن نتابعها في
هذا التقرير ثم
نعود خمسه اسابيع على الحرب البريه لم
تظهر حتى الان كتائب القسام عجزا في
القتال تشير تقديرات اسرائيليه الى ان
الالويه التي تقاتل شمالا لن تطلب دعما من
الويه مناطق القطاع الاخرى تقرر اسرائيل
توسيع العمليه اوكلت مهمه العمليات في
الجنوب للفرقه الثامنه وال9 في الجيش
الاسرائيلي وتتشكل من اللواء المظلي
ال5 واللواء المظلي
ال5 اضافه الى لواء عوز ويتشكل
من وحده دوف دوفان ووحده ماجلان ووحده
ايجوس دفعت اسرائيل ايضا باللواء المدرع
السابع ولواء جفعاتي ولواء كفير ولواء
كرياتي واللواء الخامس والكتيبه 12ث
عش في المقابل سيقاتل في خان يونس احد
ابرز الويه النخبه في القسام وهو من
الاعلى تدريبا تجهيزا لواء خانيونس لكن لا
تتوفر معلومات دقيقه حول هياكل القياده
وهرمي اتخاذ القرارات ما دون
استراتيجيه تعد العمليه العسكريه في
المحافظه واحده من الاكثر تعقيدا في مسار
الحرب تتوفر فيها جميع العناصر التي
تخشاها الجيوش التقليديه في حروب المدن
تصعب البيئه الح يه من مهمه الجيوش في
بقعه جغرافيه صغيره ذات كثافه سكانيه
عاليه والاستعداد للقتال في مثل هذه
التضاريس الجغرافيه
والديمغرافي دونه صعوبات هائله تعتمد
اسرائيل على كلاسيكيات الجيوش النظاميه
حمله جويه باستخدام ذخائر خارقه للتحصينات
لاستهداف عقد القياده
والتحكم قبل المناورات البريه اصدرت كليه
الاركان في الجيش الامريكي وست بوينت
تقريرا تحذر فيه من مخاطر التوغل
البري يقول التقرير ان استخلاص العبري
يؤكد ان القوه الجويه لم تحقق النتائج
المرجوه في عمليات سابقه
مماثله الله اكبر
اما القسام فتعتمد في القتال على ما يسمى
اصطلاحا التشكيل الهجيم اي وجود قوه
مقاتله من النخبه التي تقتبس من الجيوش
النظاميه ارتفاع مستوى الاداء
والانضباط وبعض التقاليد
العسكريه بان الجندي ينفذ اوامر القياده
كان يكمن في موقع واحد لاسابيع وان لا
يشتبك مع العدو تحت اي ظرف وان يتفادى
انكشاف موقعه مثل ما شهدنا في كمين
المغازي
اضرب اضرب
وهناك الوحدات الميدانيه التي تختص
بالاشتباك المباشر والقدره على المناوره
وسرعه التنفيذ والانسحاب وتتكون من
مجموعات صغيره العدد من فرد واحد او
اكثر طورت القسام من تكتيكاتها وباتت
قادره على الاشتباك فوق الارض وتحت الارض
دربت مقاتليها على التكيف مع نقص الاكسجين
وغياب مصادر الضوء الطبيعي وارتفاع مخاطر
مواجهه هجمات غير تقليديه كالغاز السام
الذي استخدمته اسرائيل في بعض
الانفاق دفعت اسرائيل بوحدتها من محورين
رئيسيين توغلت القوات من كيسوفيم بمستوى
الجراره لتعزل خانيونس كليا عن المحافظه
الوسطى قطعت شارع صلاح الدين واستكملت
سيرها عبر اراضي زراعيه حتى الخط الساحلي
غربا عند شارع
الرشيد بالتوازي هاجمت من محور جنوبي شرقي
من
الفخار والهدف استخدام شارع صلاح الدين
كخط فاصل جغرافيا بين شرق المحافظه وغربها
وبالتالي محاوله تشتيت جهد لواء خان يونس
عندها هذه المرحله ومع انتهاء الاسبوع
الاول للهجوم بدات متاعب اسرائيل
الفعليه تحولت المدينه نفسها من مسرح
للقتال الى وسيله
للحرب العقبه الثانيه تمثلت بتحديات الكشف
عن الانفاق
وتدميرها يعد تنظيف الانفاق بمثابه كابوس
للجنود فهي عمليه بطيئه وقاتله وتعطل
امكانيه استخدام التقنيات الحديثه على
نطاق واسع والتي يعتمد عليها الجيش
الاسرائيلي وفق عقيده معالوت اي
التفوق اساءت اسرائيل تقدير قوه خصمها
ورمت بثقلها على التكنولوجيا وهذان خطان
قاتلان في حروب المدن فهمه فرق المشاه
بحسب الامريكيين تكمن في تحديد مواقع
العدو وتدميرها وان تمكن العدو من تحييد
هذه المعادله فسيكون الاجهاز عليه امرا
مستحيلا
اللواء فيز دويري تابعنا هذا التقرير
تقرير لزميله سلام خضر يرصد نقاط القوه
ونقاط الضعف لدى المقاومه واي
جيش نظامي وكيف يفكر كلاء الطرفين في حرب
المدن لكن النقطه النهائيه التي انتهى بها
التقرير تتحدث على الجيش ان يجد اهداف او
يكتشف اهداف العدو ويتخلص منها هل استطاع
جيش الاحتلال ان يكتشف اهداف المقاومه في
خان يونس لا يعني هو اصلا لا توجد اهداف
محدده له وبالتالي هذا ما شكى منه رئيس
الاركان هاليفي اعترف
وقال ضبابيه الاهداف وعدم وضوح الاهداف
سيؤدي الى تاكل الانجازات وهذه كانت مشكله
يعاني منها رئيس الاركان لماذا لانه لا
يوجد هدف محدد الان
الاهداف يطلق عليها اهداف عامه عندما
نتحدث عن اهداف بالعمليه في المنطق
العسكري له بعدين له بعد المكان والزمان
وبالتالي انت تضع خطتك في اطار بعدي
الزمان والمكان هنا غير موجود هو يتحدث عن
اطلاق شراح الرهائن اين هم الرهائن امم
حتى هذه اللحظه لم ينقذ رهينا من ضمنها
القضاء على قاده حماس اين هم غير معروف
القضاء على حماس اين حماس اصلا عندما
اتحدث انا اتحدث في البعد العسكري القسام
وليس حماس كتنظيم سياسي نعم اين هي القسام
موجوده تحت الارض في شبكه انفاق ما هو
التوصيف لشبكه الانفاق الصندوق الاسود غير
واضح الان بعد 120 يوم يتحدث انه اكتشف
نفق
اذا الاهداف غير محدده للقائد العسكري
فبالتالي عنوان المعركه غزه الارتباك اذا
انا اردت ان اوصفها بجمله بكلمه واحده
اقول ارتباك المخطط العسكري ماذا ماذا
يمكن ان تستنبط من اعلان جيش الاحتلال انه
نفذ
150000 عمليه اجلاء لجنوده جرحى من ساحه
المعركه في في قطاع غزه اضافه الى امر اخر
له علاقه وتحدثنا به كثيرا ب الصدمات
النفسيه وطلبات الاف الجنود للعلاج النفسي
الان هو حتى هذه الجمله جمله مفتوحه هو
تحدث عن
1500 حاله انقاذ هل حاله الانقاذ حاله
فرديه مزدوجه جماعيه كل كل شخص يفسرها كما
يشاء هل يعقل ان حاله الطائره ذهبت فقط
لتنقذ جريح واحد ام مجموعه من الجرحى الم
ينقلوا بسيارات الشحن اذا هو توصيف عن
طبيعه المعركه وشده القتال ضراوه القتال
من قبل المقاومه داخل المدن داخل المدن
هنا نتحدث عن حرب يطلق عليها الحرب غير
المتناظره جيش بتنظيمه بمعداته مقابل قوات
غير نظاميه تدير معركه حتى بطريقتها
الخاصه بحيث توظف امكاناتها المحدوده
لهزيمه عدو قوي وهذا ما يجري حتى هذه
اللحظه شكرا جزيلا لك اللواء فيز دويري
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي على كل هذه
المعلومات وشكرا لكم مشاهدينا على
المتابعه على المتابعه نعم